- All right, y'all, we have
time for one last story.
I hope you enjoy.
This as what I'm liking.
(guitar strumming)
(audience cheering)
For the past 15 years,
National Geographic
photographer Joel Sartore
has crisscrossed the globe taking pictures
of every animal species in human care.
So far he's documented
over 12,000 species.
He calls his project "The Photo Ark,"
and his goal is to capture these animals
before they disappear.
But he has a bigger goal,
and since it's a new year, we
want to put a spotlight on it.
We have Joel on the line
right now to explain.
What's up, Joel?
(audience cheering)
- Hi Kelly.
- Oh my gosh.
Your pictures are so
beautiful first of all.
They're so cool.
Is it true that this
project kind of came around
like unexpectedly so?
- It did.
It did.
And believe it or not,
you're part of that story.
I bet you didn't even know that.
- No.
- My wife, Kathy, was
diagnosed with breast cancer
way back when,
when you were just starting
in on American Idol.
- [Kelly] Oh wow.
- And that's been,
that's what started "The Photo Ark"
was my desire to stay closer to home
and to do things that didn't take me away
for months on end.
That's what started "The Photo Ark."
And you know what we did,
is we watched American Idol
and we watched you win.
- Oh my gosh.
- And my wife is just fine to this day
because you cheered her up
and she's sitting right next to me.
- Oh my gosh, hello.
I love this.
Oh my gosh, oh, I'm gonna cry.
Well wait, there's a bigger goal
behind this whole thing though, right?
- Oh yeah, you bet there
is, you bet there is.
We want to teach the
world to love animals,
to introduce them.
And it's like a big
dating service in a way.
Find the animal that you love.
Learn what keeps it thriving
on the face of the earth,
no matter what walk of life
you come from, no matter what,
let's try to save all these
species in their habitats
because when we save them,
we're actually saving ourselves.
That's the big secret.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- We have to have a thriving planet
with all the species that we can imagine
in order to do well ourselves.
We are completely tied to nature.
And so that's what this
project is all about.
Get people to learn about animals,
try to figure out what makes them tick,
what they need in terms
of clean water, clean air,
a healthy forest, healthy
seas, and go forward with them.
Take them forward with us in time
so that we can all enjoy the earth.
- Absolutely.
And once again,
the photos are just
breathtakingly beautiful.
I love your work.
I'm such a big fan.
Now I'm a fan of you.
And that's so awesome
that y'all watched on Idol 20 years ago.
That's so cool.
That made me feel really good.
Thank you for telling me that.
But everybody, if you love these photos,
be sure to get Joel's new book,
"Photo Ark Wonders:
Celebrating Diversity
in the Animal Kingdom."
There's also "Photo Ark ABC."
This is my favorite for the little ones.
My kids are going to freak out over this.
Both books support his ongoing work.
Thank you so much, Joel, I'm
liking your post right now.
And please say hello
again to your wife for me.
But that's not all, Joel.
Usually, this is the point in the show
when our season-long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go-to pin
of the Kelly Clarkson Show
gives an ultimate overachiever, like Joel,
a check for $1,000.
But today, Joel's paying it
forward, 'cause he's awesome,
to give that money to the
National Geographic Society.
Thank you so much, Joel.
(audience cheering)
We love you.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] And we appreciate
you and we love this art.